ich könnte braun sein ich könnte blau sein ich
könnte violetter Himmel sein ich könnte verletzend sein ich
könnte lila sein ich könnte alles sein was du magst ich
könnte braun sein ich könnte blau sein ich
könnte gewalttätig sein Himmel ich könnte verletzend sein ich
könnte lila sein ich könnte  Sei alles was du
magst Ich könnte braun sein Ich könnte blau sein Ich
könnte gemein sein im Himmel Ich könnte
verletzend sein Ich könnte lila sein Ich könnte
alles sein was du magst Ich könnte braun sein Ich
könnte blau sein Ich könnte sein
könnte gewalttätig sein Ich könnte sein  alles, was du
magst, ich könnte braun sein, ich könnte blau sein, ich
könnte
gewalttätig sein, es wäre lila, ich könnte alles sein,
was du magst, ich könnte braun sein, ich
könnte blau sein, ich könnte gewalttätig sein, Himmel, es
könnte verletzend sein, es könnte lila sein, ich
könnte sein  alles was du magst